luxury limousines with plenty of
horsepower fill the exhibition halls at
the IAA
International Motor Show in Frankfurt
keeping their eyes peeled for new iconic
cars among all the shiny new models our
automotive scholar Ferdinand Juden
hooker from the city of Essen and Paulo
- Minelli a design professor from
Cologne today icons are hardly ever
created that is to do with new
construction technologies and each year
a new model always facelifts you can
hardly remember them all and icons live
for memory by cons usually the first to
have grasped the trends of their time
cars go with the times so a car has to
be like a chameleon it has to adapt to
its surroundings and its time the first
I am autoshow in 1897 the cool Stein
electro Valley Race the most eyebrows
but the world was not yet ready for
electric mobility and it had to give way
to the combustion engine in 1939 the
precursor to the VW Beetle received
resounding applause because it was roomy
and easy to repair it gave impetus to
automotive mobility in Germany 20 years
later all eyes were upon a little
English entry the mini boasted a
revolutionary new layout
[Music]
she bring comp up you made everything so
compact but still left space and looked
pretty cute
the Mercedes 600 appeared in 1963 and
made history as a state limousine it was
six and a half meters of luxury the
Porsche 911 was known as the 901 back
then it became the quintessential German
sports car the 60s were fantastic they
were the years of the baby boom and
Germany's economic miracle recovery from
World War Two Germany invented a new
class don't forget BMW with the 1500 and
the 1800 everything had to become faster
and more dynamic in 1975 VW introduced
its Golf GTI a compact sports car in
response to the oil crisis the Toyota
Prius combined internal combustion with
electric drive in a hybrid system for
the first time in 1997 this year many
car makers still seemed to be in search
of a strategy at a time when the
automotive future looks quite electric
Mercedes took the bold step of
introducing alongside its electric
Maybach a 1,000 horsepower racecar with
a formula 1 engine they make for a
contrary couple contrasts fascinate
people and they remain fascinating
because contrasts create friction we
think back to this beauty which is
timeless in a way BMWs showcased sleek
new sports cars with conventional
engines but in 2013 it also unveiled its
first all-electric models
it's concept-car gave a preview of the
next electric car the world could expect
from BMW
they've been I'm actually an industrial
designer which means that when I shape
an industrially manufactured product I
always consider what resources to use
and how long this design will remain and
what it means when the life cycle of the
product is over but to these models have
the stuff to become new classics other
car makers are preparing for the future
with fully self-driving gasoline-powered
cars they're high-tech but still
packaged in conventional chassis
[Music]
we're seeing models looking more and
more similar whatever company makes them
that violates the principle of the icon
maybe we'll get icons when we enter a
new dimension that of electric mobility
because it requires new design idea for
the noise design with many car
manufacturers are presenting the
electric cars of the future they aren't
in the showrooms yet but they raise
hopes that maybe the next International
Motor Show in two years will feature
real icons again
[Music]